my new review brought to you by strong
assertive women in the workplace and
awesome things like that so let's take
to say the guys up there were pretty
much convinced to watch this movie
within the first 10 seconds of this
review so let's work on the women
demographic so this movie totally has a
romantic comedy vibe to it when you
watch the trailer but it's really not
like that it's about Rachel McAdams who
is a workaholic be it a very hot one who
becomes the new executive producer of
this daytime show which is about two
steps away from getting which is
probably gonna get cancelled for the
same reason things get cancelled in real
life to be replaced by shows about crap
that people vote for but really don't
give a [ __ ] about it and Harrison the
man Ford I gave him a title in his name
he deserves it plays an old cranky
really accomplished Dan Rather type who
gets brought on as their new co-anchor
and their last hope of staying alive but
these two really great actors are not
all the movie has going for it that is
not gonna get old like not ever now I
for one thought Rachel McAdams was
awesome in this movie no not just
because of that because she was really
good and Harrison Ford once again shows
us why we should all just forgive him
for Kingdom of the Crystal Skull he's
earned it and Jeff Goldblum's in the
movie he plays Rachel McAdams boss which
I found interesting because he seems to
be in every light-hearted movie that I
happen to like whatever I ain't back him
down you know you love those dinosaurs
are gonna and for brundlefly I don't
know why that's up there this movie did
a really good job at showing you that
there's more to life than just your job
I'm talking to you workaholics out there
live a little and it was really cool to
see the crew that works there become all
close like a family under rachel mcadams
management which I also found really
interesting because in my experience
generally speaking female managers
they're [ __ ] doesn't saying in my
experience honestly up to seven that
I've worked for six of them are just
these really evil leather skin mystic
tain't crocodile women on the fast track
to becoming the crazy cat lady in a
cul-de-sac somewhere but not Rachel
McAdams she's awesome
awesome do you notice his hand goes for
it he is clearly going for the grab we
salute you my man that is why you're the
Nite Owl yeah
so from the lead actors to the
supporting actors the cast is great the
script is clever I wish you had more
cleverness to it but it was still clever
and it had a good message but since it
was written by the writer of The Devil
Wears Prada and directed by the director
of Notting Hill I will have to say I
like it as long as my friends will never
find out
that's nice dude I wasn't watching that
that's good it's a good date movie like
Terminator 2 not really though check it
out with the date and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more